Is this really reality or is it a dream
?  The
only certain thing is that this is the reality, and the bride is
just so cute [Music]
The moon is beautiful, isn't it
?  I've come up with this expression,
so I want you to
say it in words that aren't roundabout
You're the only one who can
say that to me [Music]
What kind of expression of affection does it
feel like to say that now?
Yes,
but it's twice as much as Tsukasa-chan thinks It's
normal, but I
don't take what he's saying seriously
So I don't feel like saying it today  [
music]
I'm about to
fall down Don't fall down completely naked
[music]
But I'm
glad to hear you say that I really like Tsukasa-chan's shyness
[music]